wait what did Jenna Ortega say no hey  Netflix hold on I gotta go some losers  hey buddy so remember this show you  asked for right yes fantastic I remember  that well we did season one no it's all  ready to go come to Papa oh one more  thing it's not a limited series it's  it's a it plays out over multiple  seasons  you know so  so don't cancel cancel it after season  one yeah yeah as long as you get that  here  yeah here you go thank you yeah let's  just put it on the home page real quick  here not much real estate here you know  what I mean you can just stick it  anywhere on there just  maybe you could move to too hot to  handle just move that right all right  the show was out yeah  we have to cancel your show cool  nobody's watching it I'm sorry